[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'Assemblée nationale va de nouveau
retrouver son animation le résultat des
élections telles qu'il est apparu dans
la nuit du dépouillement sur les
tableaux du ministère de l'Intérieur a
donné à l'hémicycle une physionomie
toute différente de celle d'hier
[Musique]
le ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Roger Frey pouvait annoncer que l'un NR
est disposerait avec la pointe des élus
sous l'étiquette de la Cinquième
République de la majorité absolue
situation qui ne s'était pas produite
depuis 1919
comme une liste et socialiste gagne des
sièges grâce au désistement par contre
les indépendants perds de les deux tiers
de leurs élus et le MRP le tien
une fois installé cette nouvelle
Assemblée doit soutenir l'action
nationale de redressement poursuivi par
le général de Gaulle
[Musique]
un homme de cœur tel a été la première
image du président Coty conduit les
Français au soir de son élection à la
magistrature suprême dans les affaires
publiques il fut un arbitre à la fois
respecté et affable averti et tolérant
[Musique]
pendant 5 ans on l'aura vu avec beaucoup
de simplicité représenter la France qui
les montré Paris au souverain de Grèce
ou qu'il est accueilli la reine
d'Angleterre
[Musique]
sa vie de chef d'État devait être
traversé par un deuil cruel la mort de
Madame Coty le laissait seul face aux
exigences de l'Élysée en venant
nombreuses devant l'église de la
Madeleine la foule parisienne avait
partagé sa douleur
[Musique]
puis la France s'était retrouvée en 1958
en plein drame et le président Coty
avait pris la décision d'appeler celui
qui pouvait le résoudre et laissait
alors selon ses propres paroles le
premier des Français être le premier en
France
[Applaudissements]
le président Coty s'était retiré au
Havre sa ville natale
Léa vraie qu'il avait alors accueilli
avec chaleur le pleure aujourd'hui comme
tous les Français
[Musique]
personnage familier le payeur des
allocations familiales traduit l'aide à
portée à chaque foyer pour élever ses
enfants derrière ce geste banal pour la
région parisienne comme partout en
France il y a l'immeuble de la caisse à
l'intérieur le spectacle d'une
administration des temps modernes ces
machines permettent la ponctualité des
paiements et des économies de frais de
gestion on se trouve à présent dans tous
les départements d'une organisation qui
trouve sa justification dans l'immense
et fort de solidarité entrepris depuis
15 ans on ne s'étonnera pas qu'une telle
administration vivent à l'heure de
l'électronique à partir d'un fichier
c'est la machine qui débute les feuilles
de paiement concernant 8 millions
d'enfants
les sommes versées par les allocations
familiales représentent des
investissements dont aucune autre
entreprise n'atteint le chiffre
750 milliards d'anciens francs par an
sont en effet investis dans la jeunesse
la sidérurgie investit que 235 milliards
l'électricité de France 286
c'est dire l'importance des élections de
descente les chefs de famille vont
désigner les membres des conseils
d'administration chargés de la gestion
des fonds ainsi que de l'action sociale
en diminution depuis 1936 la population
française a fait à partir de 46 des bons
prodigieux près de 43 millions à 54 les
Français viennent d'atteindre le chiffre
de 47 millions et faites qu'on n'est pas
imaginer il y a 20 ans la France est
devenue aujourd'hui le pays le plus
jeune d'Europe
les moins de 20 ans représentent
aujourd'hui près du tiers de la
population totale
grâce à quoi dans 20 ans la population
active atteindra le chiffre record de 30
millions
il ne fait pas de doute que les
investissements réalisés jusqu'ici par
les allocations familiales ont permis
aux familles d'élver une jeunesse saine
et active les producteurs de demain
[Musique]
c'est dire que de tels investissements
sont rentables toute la jeunesse qui
grandit qui remplit les écoles
d'aujourd'hui c'est le gage pour demain
de la promotion d'un pays
[Musique]
pour les chemins de fer français 1962
sera la grande année de
l'électrification après Paris Dunkerque
et Paris Marseille l'attraction
électrique à Mistral à 4h30 seulement de
Paris et la plus grande région
industrielle du pays dispose aujourd'hui
d'un réseau électrique très important
pour faire face au trafic due à
l'expansion industrielle du bassin
lorrain il a fallu aménager un nouveau
centre de triage ainsi est né le
chantier de Woippy créé de toutes pièces
la garde de triage de Woippy aura
l'importance de Villeneuve-Saint-Georges
c'est-à-dire ce qui s'est fait de mieux
en France et de plus grands en Europe
5000 wagons pourront y être triés chaque
jour
Woippy sera doté des derniers
perfectionnements de la technique
notamment en ce qui concerne
l'aiguillages automatique demain on
entreprendra la liaison Reims Marseille
les lignes électrifiées du Nord et de
l'Est apparaissent ainsi comme les
artères ou pas si l'on peut dire le pou
de l'Europe de demain
[Musique]
existe-t-il un péril singe pour le
village de minigami au Japon peut-être
c'est une histoire véridique il y a
quelques temps de cela les villageois
ont tout fait pour attirer dans leur
parc les charmants primates de la forêt
voisine ils y sont parvenus ce qui leur
a valu depuis les visites très
régulières des touristes
seulement les singes se sont très vite
conduits comme un pays conquis on ne
compte plus leur facéties leur larcin
leur pillage
[Musique]
ils sont partout et la vie est devenue
impossible et pourtant l'inégamie ne se
résout pas à choisir conserver cette
attraction pour attirer les touristes ou
chasser les pillards
et si l'advient qu'un pauvre petit singe
se prenne dans les fils électriques et
s'électrocute voilà le secouriste de
service qui se précipite et tout est mis
en œuvre pour animer la victime
[Musique]
que le singe meurt et on lui fait un
service funèbre pour que les esprits de
sa tribuent de leur influence pour faire
rester toute la troupe au village
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le moment amine et Gami les singes
demeure et le dilemme aussi
[Musique]
que peut-on faire à cette époque sur une
plage normande et surtout que justifie
un télaire de concentration
d'applications notre reporter en appui
tenir il a posé la question mes
camarades
donc bien plein quoi
alors ils viennent pas tout seul quand
même là après tout le monde s'en vrac
voyez-vous et puis pour être détrués au
chantier quand les corbeilles sont
pleines ils montent ils chargent sur ces
espèces de couffins que vous voyez là de
chaque côté des chevaux
le mystère demeurait entier restait à
suivre les chevaux au couffin chargé de
galets au bout du chemin le mystère
était encore plus épais notre reporter
se trouvait à présent devant une
véritable petite cuisine
parc de stockage trieur électrique
et même calibrage méticuleux décalé les
plus précieuses en doute mais après
les petits sont mis en 7 et les gros
sont expédiés et par wagons vous voyez
parce qu'il y a encore autre chose c'est
qu'il faut faire attention de ne pas les
casser vous les chargez tous en vrac ou
tous en sac vous savez c'est un point
d'importance parce que c'est sous le
contrôle douanier qui eut pensait que
les cailloux pourraient peser dans la
balance commerciale de la France
[Musique]
qui est riche en galet n'est-elle pas un
risque de concurrence pour vous non
jusqu'ici nous avons du beau et du bon
galet que font vos clients de ces galets
absolument rien
ça sera mince avec respect ça se vend
mais on ne saura jamais à quoi ça sert
[Musique]